تحركات جديده في مضيق تايوان نفذتها تسع
طائرات صينيه مقاتله التي عبرت خط الوسط
في المضيق الذي لطالما كان الساحه حرب غير
مباشره بين بكين وواشنطن التي تطالب
بالسياده الكامله على اراضيها اجراءات
حازمه ومضاده توعدت بها الصين وصفتها
تايوان بغير العقلانيه في اشاره الى ان
بكين تتعمد اطاله حاله من التوتر وعدم
الاستقرار في المضيق بالتزامن مع الزياره
التي تقوم بها رئيسه تايوان الى الولايات
المتحده والتي اعتبرها مراقبون جرس انذار
لها من القيام باي استفزازات جديده تغضب
بكين غير ان رئيسه تايوان تعهدت بعدم
السماح للضغط الخارجي بمنع الجزيره من
التعامل مع العالم بعد التهديدات الصينيه
مشيره الى ان تايوان مستمره في المضي قدما
نحو تحقيق سيادتها الكامله وحريتها ولا
تعد هذه المره الاولى التي تعبر فيها
طائرات صينيه مقاتله خط الوسط لمضيق
تايوان الذي لا تعترف به بكين حيث تقول ان
كل تحرك للصين داخله يعد مساسا بسيادتها
خط تتقاطع فيه مخاطر الاشتباكات السياسيه
والحوادث العسكريه نظرا لضيقه حيث لا
يتجاوز عرضه 130 كيلومترا في اضيق نقطه
فيها ولطالما شكل هذا الخط عنوان ازمه
متواتره بين تايوان والصين التي تعتبر
الجزيره جزءا من اراضيها وترفض اي علاقات
دوليه رسميه معها